hey everyone I'm Arjun and today for
about an hour and a half I'll be doing
some tactics with viewers and then after
that I'll be taking some challenges
so let's just go ahead and get started
with the first tactic
um it's on rated okay everything looks
good so you can feel free to suggest
moves in the chat or anything and I'll
be looking at that frequently so
let's just get started
this looks like uh White's king is not
too safe we have black going up this way
White's King isn't too safe it's kind of
in the middle of the board there's this
Pawn on E3 we've got two attackers on
that maybe maybe we can get something
going there
the pawn E3 is protecting the Knight
which is attacked by our Queen so maybe
there's something there and also White's
Rook is kind of out of the game although
not that our Rook on B it's doing too
much either
so okay uh what are some potential
candidate moves for us
the first one that comes to mind for me
would just be it takes E3 because
if Rook to C3 we have green D4
if the queen moves well we've won an
important Pawn in White's position maybe
we can go Knight G4 or something next
even like meeting ideas if the King goes
back to the back rank somewhere
so it looks like 93 is probably a good
start
so after Knight E3 probably a good idea
to look at some specific variations
so 93
um let's say Rook E3 Queen D4 and then
we'll have these two attackers on
White's Rook
uh sorry two attackers the queen of The
Rook at on that square so White's gonna
have to protect his Rook somehow and it
seems like probably the easiest way to
do that is to go like Queen C3
that happens what's something we can do
there with black
I don't really see what we do about
about that line so if we just go Knight
E3 Rook E3 Queen D4 Queen C3 it seems
like White's doing all right because I
think we're gonna have to move the queen
back
and then maybe something like Queen C5
comes if white can ever get a queen
trade that'll definitely be good for
them
besides 93 I don't see any any real
candidates maybe Rook E3 is possible so
like rookie 3 rookie 3 Queen D4
but I think we run into
maybe something similar like Queen D3
and then obviously we can't really trade
queens and if we trade off too many
pieces it's just going to be an equal
end game
so it looks like 93 is promising Rook E3
Queen D4 but then then what's gonna come
next
if Queen C3 Queen B6 Maybe
what do we have there
um
I guess we are we do have this sort of
D4
so maybe what might be better for white
is after 93 rookie 3 Queen D4 maybe I
can go Queen D3 instead
so that's I'll just show that one again
Knight E3 takes takes we're double
attacking this Rook so y has to go Queen
D3 because they want to protect their
Rook on E3
so then what is black gonna do there
if black was Queen B2 or something
probably why I can go King G3 safely and
I don't see them getting mated or
anything there just because Black's
Rooks are are both still on the back
rank
so I think Queen D3 might be pretty good
for white and then it doesn't look like
they've got many problems if any
so how about we take a look at this
slide so let's say we start with 93 Rook
E3 but then we go Rook E3 ourselves
so 93 rookie 3 Rook E3 King E3
say we try Queen E5
I guess black white just goes King D3
and they're still holding on to D4
so okay maybe not maybe that's not ideal
either so but something something tells
me that Knight E3 has to really has to
be the right way to start uh anyone in
the chat have any ideas
maybe 93 or another candidate move or
anything along those lines
uh one suggestion to go 93 followed by
Queen D4
yeah 93 Queen D4 that was the first
thing I was taking a look at but I think
the problem might be Queen D3
yeah uh I guess something like Queen E2
that makes it kind of hard to progress
from there
yeah so
what else could we try
um
maybe there's something on H4 that we
can try to make use of
like
could we go 93 rookie 3 followed by
Queen H4
but then I guess the G3 Queen D4 and I
don't really think it makes a difference
that I don't really think it makes much
difference that we included the queen H4
G3
because then after Queen D4 I think we
run into the the same problem with going
Queen D3 for white and then I don't see
how we're making progress after that
maybe we can maybe we can try to change
the move order a little or something
um
what else could we do
definitely I think rookie 3 doesn't work
because rookie 3 rookie three Guinea G4
Queen D3 just seems like a worse version
of going ID3 because we'll probably end
up getting into some endgame where all
of these pieces are gone and then it'll
probably just be a draw in this
so okay let's let's go back to 93 93
Rook E3 what are we gonna do there
hmm
okay how about this how about after
Knight E3 Rook E3
rookie 3 King E3
say we try going rookie eight check
and then the point is if King F2 we've
got Queen D4 that looks really good for
black
if King D2 Queen D4 again it is probably
close to winning
and if King D3
then I think we can go Queen G6
so I'll show that line again so we would
start with 93 we would trade a few times
on E3
ending with King E3 rookie eight
and now if King G3 which seems like the
only reasonable option then we have to
go then we can go Queen G6
and uh wherever the King goes let's say
the King goes to D2 then we can just go
Queen G2 and take on H1
so uh is there any agreement or
disagreement with this line just taking
a couple times going rookie eight the
point being if King D3 we have Queen G6
with this thread
I'll give everyone a second
okay uh one person says it seems logical
is there anyone else who agrees or maybe
disagrees
or if there's any other any other line
suggestions
the assignment starts after how long I
think the sign will starts at 4 15 so
that's in about two hours
but I think there's probably a command
in the chat that you can use to get
information about it
so okay we have one vote of approval for
this Knight E3 Rook E3 followed by
rookie eight line is there anyone else
who agrees or disagrees
uh what if King C3 after Queen G6 so
okay after sorry after takes takes takes
takes rookie 8 King G3 Queen G6 yeah uh
King C3 then we've got Rook C and we're
gonna win the queen
it's okay I think let's probably go for
this line it seems like it works right
now
okay it takes
then takes and rookie eight okay King F2
so I guess we have to take here
the only other thing that really kind of
makes sense would be to go Queen H4 but
then G3 and I think we're just giving
the king an extra Square
so let's take care okay and I guess that
was it
yeah white would have to play King D3 so
here uh let's just analyze it real quick
so
okay after Knight E3
takes takes
uh if white was still interested in
keeping the Knight they'd have to go
King D3
and then we go Queen G6 and if King here
we're gonna win the Rook like this
and if King C3 then we can win the queen
like this
so yeah and okay after takes
what what could happen here King F1
we've got Queen A1 and we're gonna win
the rook in the corner
and if King G3 I'm guessing there's
probably probably some way to make here
or at the very least just like get a
really really strong position
uh what could it be maybe we go like
Queen E5
if King F2 back
I don't know something like this looks
like it should be winning or we could
even just be safe like play H5 or
something to get lift and then go like
rookie five Rook G5 I don't know
something like that seems like it's
gonna win
it's okay uh I'm just curious I want to
see just what opening this came from
this was played between two 1900s and a
Blitz game
um okay so it was a ninja Indian by
transposition
and okay black out the hanging pawns
then I guess they gave away one of their
pawns at some point yeah they gave away
C3 and then there's this tactic all
right
I guess let's move on to the next one
that was pretty good
it's okay we are black again here
we've got a queen and Rook pretty close
to the enemy King white does have two
Bishops for The Rook though so in in
terms of material strictly we're we're
down a little bit but we have a lot of
play and probably there's a way that we
can get made or at least win a lot of
stuff I think
it's okay how should we how's the best
way to start
I guess first movie that comes to mind
would be to go Rook G2 for me
but Rook T2 King H1 and this bishop does
a nice job covering H2
so and we can't really afford to move
the Rook away because there's going to
be Bishop F7
so maybe Rook G2 isn't the isn't the
correct way to start
besides Richard what are some some other
initial moves
uh we could go like Queen to D4
and then that would force King H1 and
then we could do like Queen E3 or
something
because that just about it threatens me
basically over there
and
and if black isn't if white isn't able
to stop Queen takes H3 then that's gonna
just lead to mate I think
yeah we have a suggestion from bratwurst
1738 to try Queen D4
it's okay Queen G4 here let's see
besides Queen E3 what are what are some
moves that we can play with black
um
I don't think there's any options there
if we start with Queen G4 then I think
we have to go for Queen E3 next
so Queen D4 Queen E3
and we're threatening this mate
Queen G4 G5 G2 while G5 is covered by
this bishop so that doesn't work out for
us
that's why I'm thinking we should go
Queen G4 and queen E3 so our point is we
want to take on H2 or on H3
and as far as I can tell the only way to
stop it is to go Bishop H2 with block
with white because then once we take
it's not with check anymore and then our
Rook is going to hang on E2
so that that's what that's as far as I
can tell so far
what else what else can we do with with
black after that
we can't take on H2 that just doesn't
seem like it makes any sense
um
yeah I'm not sure it seems like after
after Bishop H2 I don't really see much
there
okay anyone else have any ideas after
Queen D4 maybe or if there's another
candidate move
Queen D4 and then D6 okay so I guess a
suggestion to go Queen D4 and take on D6
but I don't think that'll work yeah
because Queen E2 comes
maybe we can start some line with Rook
D2
I kind of like the idea of doing that
but I think the problem is just Queen F3
is coming next and then there's it's
still a threat on this Rook there's no
more Rook G2 ideas coming
Queen D4 just seems less strong now
because there's a rook F2 anyway
so yeah I I don't really like the idea
of going rifty two it seems to me like
Queen G4 is definitely the the strongest
book we've seen so far
so okay Queen G4 here Queen E3 Bishop H2
what are we gonna do from this position
does anyone anyone watching have any
ideas
so after Queen D4 King H1 Queen E3
Bishop H2 anything that black could do
there
there's Rook G2 check and queen B3
well yeah Queen B3 won't work because
there's white white screen is covering
that square
okay what else what else could we do
um after Queen E3 Bishop H2
it's annoying how this white Rook is
covering F3 and the pawn also perfectly
covers E4
so is there something we can do about
one of those maybe we can like divert
The Rook somehow but I don't see how
that's gonna happen
what else
Queen D4 King H1 maybe there's something
else in this position
maybe Queen E3 is not the right move but
there could be could be another line
um
Rugby 2 after Queen D4
so Queen D4 here Rook B2 I think the
issue with that is just Bishop f8
and it seems like it's just a little
slow because we don't really have a
direct threat there
uh maybe we should look for Perpetual
are we sure we're winning here we're
down material maybe we should look for a
draw
I guess we could look for a draw but it
feels like we're getting really close to
mating because
in the line with Queen D4 Queen E3
Bishop H2 I think that's the only way to
stop me
so it feels like there should be
there should be something there should
be some way to try to win
but yeah it is possible that we're we're
only going for a draw since we are down
some material
uh any any other suggestions for anyone
else so far it seems like we're kind of
hitting a dead end with this queen D4
Queen E3 line
yep anyone else have any ideas maybe
maybe not even in this line just if
there's another first move or anything
foreign
E3 okay so Queen D4 King H1 Rook E3
I think the issue with that is I think
white can just take on f8 because Rook
H3 King G2 and I don't think we have a
mate there with black
so yeah
maybe rookie and Sac on G7 with some
ideas on the doubled Rooks
oh so rookie eight here
well I think rookie the problem is
Bishop F7 is is always going to be a
problem
and I don't really ever think that we we
can survive allowing Bishop F7
and also like I guess I guess at the
very least if rookie it or something
uh Bishop F7 here then like Queen A1 and
the queen trade is gonna happen
it's okay uh what else is there
sorry uh maybe Queen D4 here
what else could we do we can't really
make Queen D6 work because E2 Falls
Queen E3 Bishop H2 I really feel like
there's something in that line
because
yeah because we're getting very close to
giving mate
Rook D2 Queen F3 Queen D4 okay so Rook
T2 Queen F3 Queen D4 I think just Rook
F2 from white or no sorry that's not
possible I guess
Rook D2 Queen F3 Queen D4 what is White
gonna do there
I didn't consider that
so Rook D2 Queen F3 Queen D4 say King H1
I guess just Queen G6
and we've won a piece
and I don't know what white is going to
do about that
say after Rook D2 white doesn't go for
Queen F3 maybe they go for like Queen C1
instead
what can we do there
I think we might actually be able to get
mate there though
so if we go Rook D2 Queen C1 Queen D4
King H1 Queen D3
then
it looks like H3 is going to fall and if
Bishop H2 like we were kind of worried
about the other line we have Queen E4
all of a sudden
Queen H2 unfortunately the bishop covers
H2 so we can't do that
so okay I really like this idea who
suggested it I think it was 1738
then we can go Rook D2
of Queen F3 just Queen D4 and we take on
on D6
and if instead of Queen F3 and if
instead Queen C1
then we can go Queen D4 King H1 Queen G3
and we attack H3
and also the bishop here so that seems
like it might be really good
uh did anyone does everyone agree with
this line or are there potentially other
suggestions
I was looking at somehow getting a check
on the a08 H1 diagonal this idea might
work I'm not sure if we'll be able to
get a check on this line but I think
that concretely we're either going to
win a bishop or we'll get made
so yeah it was a nice suggestion by
Brower 1738
I guess if one more person agrees then
we can go for it we have one one vote of
approval
okay a land Lando loves Jesus says I'm
all for it so let's go for this line
that was not it
that's surprising it seemed like a
pretty promising line
I guess maybe the problem was Queen A1
that was the line that I didn't really
look for
so I guess Rook D2 Queen A1 is probably
gonna cause problems
and then for G2 then doesn't really seem
like we have something there
it's okay uh maybe something else is
that we've been looking at Queen D4 but
it seems like we're not getting getting
much of anywhere after Queen e3 coming
next
so
and Rook G2 didn't really seem like
there was there was much there
I don't think we can ever survive moving
this Rook away
so it kind of seems like to me we have
to either go for Queen D4 Rook G2
I think Queen C1 then picked the bishop
um not sure which line exactly you're
talking about maybe is this a rook D2
line or is it something else
I'm thinking we should probably go for
Queen D4 then seeing as seeing as Rook
D2 wasn't it maybe Queen D4
uh is there anyone opposed to going for
Queen D4 or should we try Queen D4 and
see how that goes
Queen D4 but let's find a line then go
for it okay so let's let's take a look
again then windy for working H1
Queen D6 can't really be it Queen E3
looks like it works except for Bishop H2
so
at rookie three I think probably just
doesn't work because of Bishop f8
um
what else could we go for Queen E3 is
there something there we need three
Bishop H2 I feel like there has to be
something in that line
um
I I'm thinking about trying to go for
Rook D2 after so if Queen D4 King H1
Queen E3 Bishop H2 Rook D2
but then I guess there's a couple
problems probably the main one is just
queen queen F3 comes
so what else what else can we do
yeah is there any other suggestion after
Queen G4
I'm trying to see in these lines if I
can somehow free The f8 Rook but I can't
find a way yeah
uh it's I don't I don't really think we
can ever move this Rook because Bishop
F7 just seems like it comes every time
this one's not easy yet this one's
actually rated over three thousand I
don't know if you can see from the
screen I probably not but it's rated
3015. so it's not an easy puzzle
Queen E3
I guess you're probably talking about
the the same line that we've been
looking at the queen D4 Queen E3 but the
only issue is this bishop H2 move
and we don't really see where we're
going from there that's the problem
yeah and we're struggling to find the
find the follow-up there
okay uh how else can we go about it
we can't go Queen D6 or anything because
ichu will hang
we can't really we don't have time to go
Rook Rook here I don't think probably
not at least
yeah I don't I don't think we have time
to do any of that
so what else what else is there
maybe we should start looking at like
some some other idea
Queen G4 Rook F2
well for F2 after Queen D4 so for if
Queen D4 King H1 work after I assume
then they can probably just take and
take on f8 right so I don't think that's
gonna work out
is there something we can do about D3
Maybe
but I guess unfortunately we've already
looked at that Rook E3 move after Queen
D4 King H1
so after Queen D4 King H1 Rook E3 and it
doesn't really work
so okay uh what else what else can we do
foreign
I think maybe we should probably just
try Queen G4 and see if that's right
because then we'll get pointed a little
bit more in the right direction since I
think we're we're not really getting
anywhere with this one
we have agreement from a few people okay
so let's go for Queen D4 then
okay Queen D4 is also not it
so okay that kind of means that the the
two big lines Rook T2 and queen D4 that
we were looking at they don't really
seem to be working
so I guess what other moves are there
that we can even do
Rook G2 here King H1 maybe then is there
something with Rook D2
um
is there something like that that might
work
I think probably not because of like
Queen F3
and if Queen B3 then bishop f8 and it
seems like we're kind of in the same
problem again
yeah I don't really think that works
maybe a sacrifice uh I don't see any
good sacrifice unfortunately because
we're already like in danger of going
down an exchange or down I guess a full
Bishop there so
it seems strange as the queen is on a
black Square
um
I'm not sure which line you're referring
to uh where the Queen's on the black
Square are like just in general
okay one more can we try
learn practice improve it's good to see
you
Rook G2 King H1
what possibilities are there in that
position
foreign
access to C6 B7 or a
um
yeah that would be really nice if we can
get the queen on the long diagonal but I
think that's going to be really
difficult
because the bishop covers this Square
and it would right the way things are
right now there would be a two move way
to get there but that just seems very
very unrealistic
so I don't really think that that that's
something that we're going to be able to
achieve
I feel like there's probably something
after Rook G2 about it if Rook D2 and
queen D4 both didn't work then probably
there's Rook G2 some things
well the problem with Rook H2 is that
the bishop on yeah uh Bishop on D6
covers H2
so that makes it a difficult puzzle
foreign
G4 and it's also not Rook G2
maybe can we go Rook E3
and the point is that white can't take
care because we have Rook G3 coming
sorry uh White can't take because we've
got Rook G3 that comes up next
so I guess playing white there I would
probably think like Rook F2 or something
but yeah okay I guess that then
we're gonna run to the same problem that
we're just gonna lose f8 eventually
anyway
or I guess there's probably even other
ways maybe Queen C2 or something might
work
Rook E3 looks nice
uh I think that the problem with Rook E3
is just that
it's like the same thing uh probably
just Rook F2 or something and then
Bishop f8
yeah this puzzle is Pretty Tough it's
over three thousand
okay I think I'm getting a little stuck
here anyone else have any move
suggestions
so the only two we've eliminated I guess
for sure are to go Rook D2 and queen D4
yeah white stock Square Bishop is pretty
pretty annoying rookie six
um I think rookie six just Falls to
Bishop E6
so it doesn't seem like that one works
laughs
is there any like hidden like kind of
long distance queen move I don't think
any of nothing like that really makes
sense
I'd spam Brook G2 Rook d8 rookie 3 and
see if one hits
okay I I think maybe maybe the idea of
getting this workout might actually be
correct
I don't think Rook E8 makes much sense
but I guess it's possible that Rook d8
would work because if we're running to
take this bishop and I mean the bishop
can't move off of this long diagonal
because otherwise White's gonna get
mated
foreign
should we maybe try going Rook d8 then
see whether that one works or not
I guess 48 what if Rook F7
because then there's all these
discovered check possibilities
and that could be annoying
Queen D14 H1 Queen E3 yeah that's one of
the lines we spent a long time looking
at but unfortunately Queen D4 is not
right because we've tried that move
so yeah
um two like the two moves that we that
we thought were most promising
unfortunately didn't didn't end up being
correct
okay
uh if we hang F7 the problem is in many
lines white has Queen A1 forcing the
queen trade yeah so that is true that's
why I was thinking Rook d8 because if
we're threatening D6 then that takes
away one tempo from White
because then if let's say Rook d8 Bishop
F7
eh1 Queen A1 we can go Rook D6 and we're
gonna still end up material at the end
yeah
okay
um
uh anyone else have any ideas like maybe
another movie Rook d8 Rook E8
is there any line that might work here
I think we should probably try something
like Rook d8 and see whether or not that
ends up being it
Rook date Rook F7 Rook D6 loses to Rook
F2 I believe
yeah that's also true Rook F7 is a
really is a strong maybe probably
stronger than Bishop F7 because then
there's just all those threats on the
next move
okay maybe it's maybe it's some sort of
a quieter move
but I guess the problem with trying to
quiet move here is just that white
already has his own threats because
Bishop f8 comes then after that like
Rook F7 and so we're gonna get mated if
we don't do anything quick
what happens on Rook D2
uh Rook D2 then Queen A1 is I think
probably why it didn't work yeah that
seems like the issue although we could
we could take a look at it in more
detail afterward
uh Queen A1 Rook G2 queen king H1 Queen
B3 King G2 Queen D5 is my idea
um well we the thing is we also already
tried Rook D2 so we know that that isn't
the correct move
and that your line totally makes sense
but I think since the material is just
equal at the end it's probably not gonna
it probably wouldn't be right anyway
since it seems to me like given how
strong our Rooks are we're probably
going to be trying to win
it's okay
um let's let's keep looking for other
ideas
Rook C8 perhaps but then I guess
is it going to be the same issue here
with this move coming
Rook F7
say we go Rook C1
no I think something like Rook F1
probably comes and then that's that's a
problem
Rook d8 Rook F7 what is our answer yeah
I don't see anything there really after
Rook d8 either
but that seems like the the closest
we've come so far to getting a solution
uh since we've been on this one for a
while maybe we should just try Rook G2
Rook G2 was like the very first move
that we ended up considering but it
didn't seem like it worked out but
possibly there's something that we're
just missing there
okay uh does anyone think that we should
just go for Rook G2 and see if that
works out
I'll give everyone a few seconds
there's no huge gain
um
rookie2 King H1 Rook F2 was considered
I think that the problem with going for
graphq there is that after takes takes
and takes on d8 we don't really have
much
Rook G2 King H1 wrote D2
um
I I guess that makes sense but I think
probably like Queen A1 or something
and then
um
or sorry not Queen A1 uh if like Queen
F3 or something
Rook G2 Queen F3
and then I don't really see what we're
doing from there
but we can try it I guess so I think
it's probably time to try another move
so let's see if Rook G2 is it
okay Rook chichu is also not the right
move
it's okay yeah Rook G2 didn't make too
much sense I guess so I I think it's not
really a question that we think we're
seeing something and that ends up being
not being it just that we haven't really
seen a winning line yet
so okay let's let's keep looking for a
little bit longer
I feel like it might be a root move just
because
I don't know it seems like that's kind
of the only thing that's been working
out or it seemed like that's the only
thing we haven't really tried it might
be moving this Rook somewhere
if we go rookie E8 say Rook F7
um
I don't think we can afford to try
rookie one because then Rook F1 comes
what about Queen d14h1 Queen E3 yeah
that was originally what we thought but
we've already tried Queen G4 and it
wasn't it but also I think the reason it
doesn't work is because of Bishop H2
okay
um
how about something else could it be a
king move maybe
like a king move to then so that then
Rook F7 doesn't carry with any
discoveries
but I guess then Queen A1 and that
that's our problem once again
did we try rookie 3 Rook F3 Queen C3
Bishop f8 King takes eight and we win
material
uh after rookie three Rook F3 how do we
go why does why do we do queen C3
I think you might have skipped a move in
that line
rookie 3 Rook F3 Rook F3 Queen F3 and
then Queen C2 I think you mean queen B3
at the end
but
um
yeah you're fine uh so rookie 3 Rook F3
takes takes Queen B3 Bishop f8 King f8
I guess it could be that just try to get
an equal position
I think at this point it's probably
worth it to try anything
so maybe should we just try for Rook E3
see if it works
just because we've been on this one for
about 40 minutes so don't want to end up
spending too long on one
a regaffeine bishop F7 King G7 Bishop E8
Queen D4 works out that's true if the
bishop ever stops covering D5 then this
whole Queen D4 line is going to work
okay I think let's try a separate 90
separate 90 ones idea
yeah I think we should probably try that
one first and then maybe we can go for
Rook E8 then
so okay let's try Rook E3
rookie 3 also wasn't it okay that's four
incorrect attempts so far
that's not too good
okay so now we've got that suggestion
from chess lovers saying uh try rookie
eight
is there any more checks if we played
Rook C8 with the idea of getting the
Rook to C1
I've Rook C8 then say
just Bishop Rook F7
and I think the issue with going Rook C1
is that then there's Rook F1
because it's it's discovered a check on
the king
and then we're gonna win E1 win C1 right
after that
so I don't think that Rook C8 quite
works unfortunately
uh I can tell you the first move if you
want maybe let's try a couple more
minutes of just trying moves I guess and
then I think at some point we'll be able
to just stumble upon the correct move so
thanks for the offer but I think
probably not
okay
um
how about we try for rookie eight I
think that was suggested by chess lover
a little bit ago
rookie Bishop 17 were threatening Rook 8
to E3 that's true
that that that that makes a lot of sense
then because if we're here then Bishop
F7 and we have this Rook E3 threat and
that's not too easy to deal with
so okay let's let's try this let's try
rookie a
rookie was correct to start off Bishop
F7
um should we go King G7 or King h8 then
after that
um
what difference could it make
King G7 okay I guess we'll we can go for
King G7
King G7 Queen A1
oh okay and now
I think I'm starting to see it just we
take probably
okay that was a really difficult one
here let's go back and analyze that then
okay uh I don't know if I don't think I
can probably turn on the engine just
because it's been causing lag lately to
try turning on the engine let's see how
much this we can analyze on our own
so okay we tried Rook D2 at first but I
think Queen A1 is why it doesn't work
if Queen F3 or something we can go for
this line we take on D6 and this is
probably winning for black
just if something like this happens
and
uh but if I think the refutation this is
Queen A1 and then
we don't really have much because it's
gonna just get to this position
then the next line we had tried was I
think it was Queen D4 that we attempted
next
and we thought of this line but then
Bishop H2 and all of a sudden we don't
really have anything with black
so that was the problem there
Rook T2 and none of us really saw
anything after King H1
I think this this problem just kind of
persists that
uh the The Rook is hanging so we would
have gotten to something like this which
is probably equal
but then
um Rook rookie 8 King G7
it takes then we have Queen D4 and then
here going for Queen G2
uh I don't know if you're winning after
Queen M1 rookie one king F7 Rook a seven
here okay I think definitely black
should win this but yeah it's not it's
definitely not like an easy win because
white does have two pawns for the
exchange
I think the way black wins is just
because White's King is cut off on this
rank since this Rook is really strong
covering all these squares here
but yeah definitely it was a tough
puzzle